yeah hello and welcome to this new 2510
rapid game so let's see what we can do
here what to play me hmm can I do
something different i could but so let's
play the goon fault and challenge myself
a little bit with this opening that i
don't know what this is very quickly
dashing out the moves so this is about
what i know Bishop g4 f 395 this is the
old main line like from the 80s and 90s
i think nowadays they also play just
Bishop d7 here it's also be six if i'm
not mistaken okay i'll shoot for Bishop
d7 and let's hope that my opponent is
not just like a dashing our moves and
killing me I really am not very
knowledgeable here
Bishop d7 is preparing possible oopsie
aight like it's not afraid much of white
taking on c5 sometimes this can be an
option though sometimes underestimated
that idea it kills white some one
structure now he is playing it it kills
White's pawn structure but on the other
hand we can also serve as some guy
gaining a little bit of space
controlling be 66 and so on so what am I
doing here just Queen to c7 that looks
like a normal reply yeah I guess Quincy
sound I have to connect rooks and the
ideal scenario here for black is
something like I guess moving something
like six moving the rook they have a
drogue when Bishop f8 and getting the
pawn back if i manage that i probably
have a really good position I wonder if
Knight a5 is part of that that who will
set up
yeah it kind of it kind of fits in them
of a plane 95 the bishop goes to be
three I think I'm also quite satisfied
that the B file is closed so Bishop d3
looks completely wrong so this one so
maybe roop da de loop the aid preparing
that e6 business what is happening after
d8c having does he have something on the
one f7 here don't see it look ft 8 4 e 6
bishop evade
it looks a little bit wrong to move the
look away from evade somehow with f7
being under pressure and I cannot take
on be 39 he will recapture with this
pawn but I it's not that clear but it's
not not really what I want to do maybe
still this I mean the move that I was a
little bit concerned about is is f4 fy5
but f-for now runs into this Bishop
discoveries that I mean should be five
in particular looks worrisome okay so
that's an interesting moment here e 6f
form the ship f8f five you should take
35 mm camera
mm6 I wonder if thats I'm drawn back
within six on the dark squares for
example but currently I don't see it we
should therefore i take c 5
e 6f form the ship f8f five should see
five txtx now why definitely has play
them but at the end of the sequence i
canna can't eat once be three though so
probably probably this is okay
we should g5i probably a guru ki aid not
allowing any Bishop e7 ideas now white
now but nobody has to think about this
if he he doesn't see how he plays a
somewhat slow move yeah I mean I don't
know if you can't afford for that so
easily so Bishop fa diem trying to get
that back yeah so it seems that they
absolutely only plan that I know in this
position and it's going to going to
happen after d takes d5 just getting the
porn back with a new land well if I just
get it without any any concrete issue
then I'm really happy with my position
here
yeah so the rook somewhere see 808 set
the difference rukon c8 looks more
active and regards to the c3 porn so
probably do that Bishop g5 sorry Bishop
f4 Bishop g5 to f4 now is an interesting
idea because at this particular moment I
cannot capture on c5 SD 7s hanging so I
have to go a five if I he can actually
take I up and then look 27 hmm besides
unfortunate
well that's very unfortunate if five
takes rook t7 the Knight takes Queen
chicks actually reduce the threat on f7
that's pretty awful but kundi aid also
looks awful with the D file I like I
don't quite see yet how it is going to
be completely refuted
hmm
wow so I needed to go to EA de so that I
have Quincy aid maybe you can then
Bishop this six
ok it's Queen to c6 a playable move or
is that completely completely bad Wow if
I every seems entirely on player Bishop
takes Queen takes root e70 looks
absolutely awful 26 also looks awful the
turn Quincy 694 it should work ok I have
to I don't like to but I have to
yeah maybe just Bishop t6 now in this
position push-up the sixth and also
introduces the 94 IDM 94 now i think i
can take c5 and he's got no particularly
particularly great way to explore that a
bishop d6 is just good i don't see sorry
don't see a good reply to that move
yep
so if I take it he's going to cheat with
the pawn and it's not clear how I ever
get it back probably I don't well there
are some chances to get it back because
the point is not so easily supported a
chick gets pawn takes Quincy five at
this 'if I've is not it's not easily
available the thing is here also yeah
might just have a five him
an idea is always be six just to give
that pawn I mean CJ's a takes this kind
of thing well you cannot take but let's
say it takes on F aid and takes on p6
wide is just a pawn down a pawn up but
not so easy to to win the position
because of blacks pressure on the A&C
pawn so b6 is not yeah it's not
downright terrible
two
yeah I wonder this some better move here
than taking I mean I don't want to take
but it's very difficulty at you to do
anything
so it's I cannot attack that c5 point is
a leaf lettuce elysium night only five
it's not doing much
well now it's it's it's really bad
position I can maybe play but should be
eight Queen a six this kind of thing
getting the Queen them it's all nice
good but it's still a big porn yeah
anyway I have to have to do something
eventually yeah that went terribly wrong
that look d to c 8 movie that was far
too quickly play this one I just didn't
pay much attention than that he's got
Bishop f4 back and he five then failed
to youtube you should be five pretty
awful so he went to five young ok so
what to do now
I wonder ever should use that Bishop
some sometimes but sometime two should
be seven or something or Bishop h6
trying to claim that the bishop 1d6 is
pretty but doesn't do much that's a
pretty pretty difficult thing to claim
if i take on d6 here by the way up
ticket and I guess the sea porn will
take or I can't even play Quincy five
there's d7 then
I don't see a good move here looks
pretty awkward maybe I can night see
sexy 67 something like that I'd c6e 7f
547 yeah
yeah I or the pretty awful game this out
to him
like might have Bishop to b5 there
should be five and then the Bishop to c4
something like that I mean I'm not quite
sure what it is doing but it's something
that I can try okay who's the king to
the side
mmm so Bishop b5 to see for maybe let's
see only eight it's not exactly
brilliant
we not see for its arts a lot not making
a huge difference but at least it has
some kind of activity and tries to stop
any pressure on the b3 e6 f7 this is
diagonal oh it takes that's a surprise
pleasant surprise actually white white a
king
hmm I thought you would just keep the
tension there okay it's still not yeah
it's not great for me but at least I
have some kind of idea yesterday night a
three very simple idea but yeah you
never know sometimes a simple ideas are
rather effective ok so this 197 is under
on the agenda tonight III probably does
not work you can take and take the seven
well 97 I can take and play 93 that is
not not really a threat the thing is
what what is what is what am i doing
with that night damn the long run
clean before is a move that white might
have
hmm yeah how do i play this Queen to e4
maybe I have to laugh and also doesn't
help be 6,000 can be six but you have
screen for anyway hmm yeah I don't know
where to go
maybe I have to go b6 no way around then
be 697 takes takes my day 3 24 is a very
rien knowing mine
I have a happy I do that many squares
them Quincy six yeah I know don't see a
really good move here Queen a form i
thought a six hoping for some counter
play like Quincy for a b5 ki will be
five look a to but v 7s hanging I
probably is a good line
well that is a good line and a sexy can
also go no 94 you cannot play a case
going there here thought Knight a5 I
mean without much enthusiasm but oh wait
I can actually also take these six this
is something that I should look at
who should be six is that so bad Bishop
t69 Teague's
night cheeks hmm do I have an
alternative Knight a5 was my original
intention 4 p-6
yeah it's pretty often anyway so Bishop
t6 9696 seat XD six and then p 7s
hanging and t7 laser is in the air it's
probably won't work so let's go back
yeah if he goes green a for a quick be4
i go be 60 okay meaning I I can not
think I can still go i go to see far is
going to be form yeah well if i go b6
now Bishop c8 I saw a bishop f8 i will
have to check with the rook pretty awful
yeah but come on it's probably not
avoidable
now Bishop f8 King takes it takes on b6
with a check and wins the size of
material
yeah I'm quite clearly not happy with my
position but we yeah it's also not
necessary to be in complete despair if
in this situation with ctx be 68 x b6 I
still have play against those three
pawns 'if I've see three and a two and
this is not a full compensation but it
is not so easy for white to play this
position I mean things didn't didn't go
well but it's important to not be too
pessimistic if you sow fear you have
some kind of some kind of play available
so here I'm kind of wondering what is
the why is he thinking here what is the
service special idea that I don't see
something like 94 I probably have Queen
to e form
yeah so it's going to deform
94 is a move but he would answer with an
attack on my nose and then it didn't
have it all
so 24 is moving back road help look II
one it's not a big deal i think i have
25 and yeah f3 when I can still go to be
seven nope any of check the night anyway
so here I cannot take the King have to
check with the rook and at least now
there are some things that I attack as
well if I for example okay here mmm
night see for taking think I'm taking or
think I'm taking
okay so
keeps that but I can go here right
intending nite nite discoveries and then
looking at the a troop on I think I'm
okay here would be I don't think that
white has an easy life here with this
pawn I have decent counterplay ideas
okay if I take a to hear what is the big
deal probably no big deal if he takes b6
I can even capture an f2 okay night c4
is also a move but then you might move
the a pawn okay let's grab
hmm so I've got one pawn back taking
their I can take be too I'm a bit
suppressor I i can take f2 that's what I
was trying to say yeah now he's offering
a draw hmm ok don't quite see why
exactly i mean i understand that he
didn't like so much what happened in the
last couple of moves but still there is
no big reason to to go for drawn so i
can take f 2 is there a reason not to do
that look everyone now that night x 6 is
not not a huge issue when i donate five
looks bad but it can go to c4 with the
tempo that's of course possible here as
well
hmm f2 is a pretty good point to take
actually okay let's grab it oh I didn't
consider that move at all have to go to
edge for now here right
would be eight and started do the stuff
so i have to go here we can also go to
f4 this is this is important let's not
be too quick there f4 is actually in a
more interesting square as it keeps an
eye on f1 for possible back rank
business and
now that's the better structure now of
course he's got to split pawns them but
my night is a little bit of 1c4 okay not
see for now or you know where is he
going with the Queen I'm attacking you
five
let's do it you five is a checked and
there are ideas with the night 92 and
some point 193 it's not so easy to make
work but if I just can get the night
from here five let's say to d5 the
position would ya improve immensely and
also easily to an advantage so I mean
it's clear that i can try now here and
be with the with this with this better
structure Jim and it's got some some bad
squares that you can go to running into
forks v5 is also under fire I mean queen
bee five there's not a three for example
that's not helping Quincy five plus rook
c8 looks well yeah he's got 96 male and
going for some some folks on his own
so what to do yeah my rook c8 96 is
awkward night 97 is quite an annoying
resource
and that's six is a bitter a bit awful
so any false will moves here with my
night just love to get it to the 593 is
not working unfortunately can even just
take 96 I think
hmm and he's got look everyone coming
yep the Quincy five was a good good
reply
yeah look everyone is bad I mean if I
like rook c8 96 moves the king he's got
Luke f1 this is really awful
can I t 2 i'm not quite sure where i'm
going with that move
hmm I don't see a good reply here if I
go nighty 390 xe6 pawn takes c6 context
III and it has good chances to draw
maybe maybe but 93 also it looks kind of
shaky anyway 93 90 x is 6 there are some
other possible reply my queen hangs so
between a five maybe between a five is
ruckus attacked that's actually possible
let's let's do that
but also that 96 f takes is six that end
game is pretty okay 96 f takes Queen III
Queen takes c3 rook takes c3 rugae too I
mean nothing great ok just this move I
didn't consider at all because 95 I
thought it's just good isn't it what is
wrong with the move look I moves the
rook and sacrifices or something I don't
see it I can also start with the rookie
move the Knights is six ok so let's
still go here
or is c4 is that that I thought c4 there
should be 93 and why does kind of
uncoordinated that that looks wrong d
for his loose and so on I mean this is
an awfully unkink read way to her to see
it but I didn't have I mean I didn't
consider that at all that he just allows
the night to come to d5 I'm threatening
rook c8 now yeah rook c8 knight c6 route
a six and white is probably in bad shape
but he will play some kind of Temple
with no anyway something that it takes
my queen or something along along these
lines yeah this is a move so Queen g4s
or g5 that's an interesting question
down now let's go to g5 don't have much
time anyway c4 night f4 looks good with
93 and night age three threatening
Knight f3 I might just play Queen to e7
note that this is 25 10 10 second
increments so okay yeah so I'm not I'm
not just going to lose on time because i
had invested time earlier i can with
relatively quick play i can draw I know
what the owners do you want I just have
when if you're not getting huge pressure
on the f porn you just lost here with
your structure so I'm not going to make
going to accept the draw him our lost is
a bit much but he's in trouble with his
with his weak bones it's just a matter
of Kim getting activity I with Knight to
g5 or things like that
ok so it tries for root could be seven i
guess i go here ok Knight to c6 let's
look at four so I have to allow a trade
so what now do I am mmm if I just go
knight c6 night a 50 checking that pawn
ya can't do that but
I think I'll start with this and rook
and 96 difficult for him than to ever
move anything but the problem is that i
have g6 played a little bit if he goes
like g45 yeah
let's go over to a three
yeah you know what's not so easy if ya
ever hear it collects III what what does
your move what our our White's moves now
okay it's going back that's maybe also
the more prudent decision in many cases
now hmm cannot go see five anyway if he
moves the night I have Luke age three so
I'm going show you get the King King
into the game check
I check on before mm-hmm where is he
going check in for looks it too why did
somebody overextended here route before
that's not see too so how do you defend
this now Kingda form
let's see it's not so easy to play I
mean only issues he's got lots lots more
time him
how to do that yeah that's also easy
firm to do play this position Roxy 396
checking t3 know is going there draw
Arthur I come on this is getting
annoying here I'm not taking a draw yeah
you should have understood by now it's
also really no reason to the position is
still kind of interesting so yeah let's
go here
time warning if five this it's difficult
oh and raised got root before
I have no clear way here to do anything
96 maybe and then trying to switch
attention to the e5 pawn 96 Ruby success
Roxy 496 will be five rooks III or dare
to something like that
yeah this is interesting I've got this
chick him I was actually thinking I
could go nite be seven but that he can
just take of course hey it could be a
problem yeah no I didn't see didn't see
that 97 was not possibly can be six now
know is going there
hmm yeah he's got King b6 coming
unfortunately amongst others so yeah it
might be 54 94-95 was good i didn't i
didn't pay enough attention to that
possibility absolutely didn't
and that's a bit bad to lose that game
completely unnecessary loss 96 now winds
pretty clearly I cannot take g5 only
hope is that I can maybe trade some
stuff but ok it's it's losing now can he
can shake and go clean c64 made but I
didn't have had had the defense anyway
yeah ok let's made on route 27 laughs
yeah I think it was okay for me to
decline the drawers because black is
just better here but I didn't play it
right yeah kind of interested in what I
did wrong yeah okay this is this was
interesting at least i'm not sure about
it but just interesting to play like
that now I get the King over here yeah
9495 is very annoying I was I was just I
was just assuming I can check him he on
97 so at the King has to go to be fired
but of course it just takes it and I'm
losing my rook that was the problem here
now the engine actually gives this a
still playable I don't necessarily need
to lose but it looks bad
yeah i don't know i don't think i need
to get into this maybe i have to improve
around here around here i'm definitely
just better I mean without any any
argument here it's just not clear to me
how I should do it I it's not much but
those pawns are just weak so my rook is
active the engine gives me a slight edge
0.3 so not much but enough to never lose
Knight a5 if it wants to play now maybe
it's it's difficult to to win it and I
could twin g4 is clearly better for
black yeah maybe I was happy with the
Queen's off with time time ticking down
because it's a position that well I know
I mean unless you play it as badly as I
did it's a position that you can only
win and never lose this is however much
stronger threatening rook c8 okay for
now flex clearly better engine is on
minus 0.8 at cesis it's also it's
difficult for y to move here it's not
easy to find a playable move the engine
gives something like this
Jim but the clear advantage from black
you're not completely convinced but
that's clearly better than going into
the endgame this end game is better for
black but it's not not the best possible
way to play it's also questionable if I
did this right I mean I probably lost to
move somewhere here could have saved the
temple group the aid or something like
that but it's not not bad I mean
according if your purim take the
circumstances with the time into account
I'm still kind of kind of okay with what
I did and this also cannot be bad yeah
and maybe looking for maybe look a for
roots III then like that now the pods
are weak but he's active enough so it's
not a it's not a substantial thing here
check check yeah I was actually thinking
that this should be should be good but
check it wasn't really wasn't an IP 5 is
incredibly problematic Chan young rookie
to I can still play that is the move
that finally loses looking to I can
still playing
the engine is just giving why the slight
edge well that's some very theoretical
possibility with no time yeah and now my
night is strapped ok I would like to
briefly check if he could have killed me
earlier because of that really miss
played opening so I was actually
thinking of that I'm in very good shape
this is is just a bad move I should go
here that is much better and T I have
good chances to get this back Bishop and
for now I can answer with e five for
example yeah that's a pretty bad
decision I didn't see Bishop f4 before
and no and I cannot go with you fire
this is the problem he will just take it
and I'm collapsing on f7 yeah you really
let me let me somehow out of this with a
couple of couple of decisions then I
don't know it looks still bad somewhere
around here I think f took it windows
down here the engine evaluation not sure
how bad this is in fact I mean this is
this kind of structure isn't so bad as
all three pawns that he has a week now
that was one possibility night c4 was
also okay he I'm definitely okay it's
just a pong has no other and and I will
get it get stuff back yeah the real
problem was that this took me five
minutes to figure out that this is that
this is actually good and he just played
this which is just a bad move he cannot
allow me to go to d5 um but he's still
played it and quickly as usual and after
that i'm just-just pretty pretty pretty
comfortable but it it was the problem
with the time later that that has spent
from four minutes there for her move
that was really far too long and I was
also trying to figure out if I can do
this but knight c6 King g7 rook f1 it's
just not good yeah here I can also go
here that's not it's another engine
suggestion that does make quite some
sense trying to take on d4 but 95 is a
logical move of course yahia Quincy for
that's a very good improvement and maybe
the one moment in the game way I really
could have gotten something the way it
went that end game it wasn't bad but it
wasn't as good as I thought with the
beat pawns okay well thanks for watching